they said your name is disparaging the
persons of Asian descent and I took a
second method will do they no evasion
dissent
I am Meredith Bragg the recent TV today
we are talking with Simon Tam he is the
bass player and the founder of the slant
they are in Washington DC the play a few
shows but more importantly they will be
fighting for the right to trademark
their name as the United States Supreme
Court on Wednesday thank you for being
here thanks for having me so very
briefly give us a quick history why did
you form the band how did you come up
with the name back in about 2004 so I
had just moved to Portland Oregon I
dropped out of college to tour in a punk
rock band we're on that time period some
of the dije you should really check out
this movie called Kill Bill and I'm
watching this movie in my apartment and
there's this really iconic scene this
woman named Warren II she kind of walks
into this restaurant with all these
mafia members behind her and you know
for most people this was just another
trademark Quentin Tarantino scene but
for me it was like I kinda pissed to me
I just had to stop there pause the film
and talk on why it was like different
for me and then I realized it was the
first time that I had ever seen an
American produced film that depicted
Asians as cool confident sexy and I was
like wow like the the art forms that I
love music has the same issue there are
no asian-americans on the cover rolling
stone on the Billboard charts been on
MTV back Lemay's to play music videos so
I thought something's got to change and
so I wanted to not be the token guy in
the band anymore I want to start my own
band that would just kind of celebrate
that culture and that's when I got the
idea of starting this Asian American
kind of project now to throughout that
process I started asking people like hey
what's the thing you think all Asians
have in common I'll try to think of a
band name here and they told me slanted
eyes and I thought you know that's
really interesting because number one
it's not true but number two we can use
it talk about our slant on life as
people of color and number three it
sounds like you know the kind of a band
Debbie Harry would
I was like this is perfect and so then
we became this plan you wanted a
trademark your name why was that
important we had been touring for for a
while and we were already doing pretty
well we did a couple national tours and
PR all things considered did the story
on us because we were like busted and to
animate mentions and playing for like
this geek army and around that time
period friend of mine his attorney said
hey Simon I really think you should get
a trademark on your band name it's
really important for bands to do who are
going to the next level and he said you
know let me handle it for you it will
only be a couple hundred bucks and about
six months this whole thing will be over
with of course things turned out a
little bit different because almost a
decade later Here I am fighting for this
right at the the Supreme Court as well
but you know it's interesting because
like when when people are talking about
these issues about trademark rights they
keep saying like things that like
basically saying it's not important for
bands or musicians to have they keep
saying well you know mr. Tam can so use
the name of the band if he wants but the
reality is that it affects musicians
much more so than they think and we
don't have a trademark registration it's
way more difficult to get a record label
offer or licensing deals or other things
that are critical for a you know
up-and-coming music business did you
think at the time that it was going to
be provocative the name has never been
provocative I actually thought it was
kind of funny I thought okay we can kind
of flip this floor around and do you
like a positive self empowering kind of
thing with the word but that being said
like I had never been called a slant my
whole life I've been called many other
things all sorts of colorful words that
people can think of for Asian Americans
but Lance was not one of them so I
thought this is kind of a clever fun
take on it the US Patent Office denied
your trademark why you know when I first
got the call for this I thought it was a
practical joke and my attorney calls me
and he says he Simon we got a problem
the the Trademark Office actually
rejected your application and I said
well you know
did I spell something out incorrectly
did
have been wrong they said no now all
that's fine is that but they said your
name is disparaging the persons of Asian
descent and I took a second method well
do they know we're of Asian descent we
just did this tour we worked with over
100 plus shows across America with Asian
American festivals who did they find
that said it was disparaging and I said
nobody but they did cite
urbandictionary.com they found an old
Wikipedia entry and then they showed a
photograph of Miley Cyrus pulling her
eyes back that's why I gesture are you
serious that's my stuff like you can't
even put the stuff in a junior high
classroom and haven't accepted why is it
either government using this so we
decided to appeal we thought they're
just completely off-base and we found
out over the years over and over again
they continue to use like really
questionable evidence just because they
want to justify their decision even
though they knew it was wrong especially
is rock need to be came from a punk
background it is littered the history of
music and punk music and rock music is
littered with names specifically
designed to provoke why are those fine
and like what's different about your
band names so I'm not sure I mean when
we asked them I said hold on a second
you know there's if slant is a an
inherent racial slur or lucky claim it
is why do you have over 800 other
trademark registrations for slant if
it's really racist towards Asians why
did you give it out to hundreds of
people but you denied it in this case
the government said it is incontestable
that the applicant is a part of an Asian
group and is of Asian descent in other
words what they're saying is the problem
isn't with the name of the band it's
with us being Asian and using the name
as a band because the meta minds if
people go to a concert and they see a
bank oldest plants and there's much
Asians on stage or they go to Lance comm
and they see photos of Asian Americans
on there they're going to automatically
think of a racial slur and not any other
possible definition
but biological contract like that
basically means anyone can register our
trademark for this plant as long as
they're not Asian so in their goals
trying to fight racism they're denying
me rights
based on my race and that simply can't
stand in your mind who gets to decide
what is offensive I mean I think
offensiveness is up to the individual
person and really it's up to you if you
want to accept that offensiveness like
as an insult from someone else or not
it's not up to the government you can't
write a law about it especially because
cultures and language they shift over
time frankly that's bad law you know
it's bad law to try and decide what's
offensive and not after this we're
hitting the road we go on tour this
spring and we're going to do a
cross-country tour of course the Supreme
Court decision is going to come out when
it comes out probably late summer early
fall but we're going to continue
recording music playing it touring
releasing music videos and doing all the
clips at a band should do that doesn't
have a giant court case hanging over I
look really excited
[Music]
you
[Music]